avec caleb maupin journaliste politique
pour rt america c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur
bonsoir qu'elle est bonne pas un merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
réseau social en l'occurrence twitter
qui défient le président américain il
faut quand même une certaine audace
n'êtes pas wendy twitter étiquette 7
les déclarations du président sur
twitter qui tend qu'à une disons qu'on
ne sont pas fondées et remettez en
question sur ce qu'il affirme bien sûr
donald trump et la maison blanche
ils n'ont pas pris calmement
donald trump et beaucoup de
conservateurs aux états unis d'une scène
qu'il ya une répression aux états unis
depuis les élections en 2016 il ya
beaucoup d'efforts afin de contrôler les
informations qu'ils allouent alain
contre tu ne réussis du discours libéral
dans les pays occidentaux capitaliste et
que ces efforts avaient mené un lien
politique qui a contre les conservateurs
aux états unis alors les menaces de
donald trump
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs même décret qui
vise les réseaux sociaux il aimerait on
clair faire fermer twitter est ce que
vraiment ça paraît réaliste que donald
trump puisse aller jusqu'au bout il a
effectivement évoqué la possibilité de
fermer twitter mais cela serait assez
complexe à suivant la constitution
américaine
le département de la justice américain
étudie le la question de savoir si
google apple twitter ou facebook fonte à
l'encontre des lois antimonopoles mai
aux états unis car elle n'est pas
vraiment de compétition dans ce domaine
et si le travail en tant que monopole
alors il n'y a aucun aucune façon de
pouvoir les décrire en tant que
compagnie qu'entreprises privées qui
sont utilisé cet argument pour dire
qu'il s'agissait de censure donc il
s'agirait alors d'une violation de la
liberté d'expression mais c'est aux
entreprises ont utilisé le marché libre
en tant que défense mais aujourd'hui ils
sont essentiels l'énergie américaine ne
peut pas vous retirez l'électricité
d'autres entreprises ne peuvent pas vous
couper l'eau si vous avez aimé des
documents qui leur déplaisent et
beaucoup de personnes considèrent que
c'est la même chose avec twitter et
facebook car il s'agit de monopole dont
on ne peut pas éviter justement c'était
ma prochaine question est ce que twitter
est pour ainsi dire sorti de son rôle
est finalement fait de la politique
depuis 2016 il y à un barrage dans les
réseaux sociaux nous demanda à twitter
ou à facebook de lutter contre les
théories du complot aux états unis mais
lorsqu'on entre dans les détails
la situation du ver très complexe si
quelqu'un propose une opinion
alternative par exemple on sent la clé
mais considère qu'il s'agit d'une
théorie du complot même si la personne
n'évoque que des faits prouvés
donald trump récemment à soulever
certaines questions sur les réseaux
sociaux concernant joe scarborough
on a considéré qu'il s'agissait d'une
théorie du complot mais la première
personne avoir évoqué le sujet n'était
pas un conservateur ou une personne de
droite s'étaient mal que lourd ce
réalisateur tiab
il reçu plusieurs récompenses il parlait
de lorik la souris sur l'assistance de
deux matrones qui est morte dans des
circonstances mystérieuses
lorsque vous êtes 38 même on parle alors
il s'agit d'une théorie du complot
il y a et beaucoup de billets facebook
ou de vidéos sur youtube ont été
supprimés donc pourquoi une entreprise
privée les personnes n'ont pas été élues
tu pourquoi ces personnes
auraient-elles l'autorité de considérer
qu'il s'agit de théories du complot dans
certains cas et dans notre cas de
questions légitimes cela semble injuste
notamment ceux qu'il n'aime pas été élu
donc ces personnes de plus sont plutôt
en faveur du parti démocrate il ya
beaucoup de libertarisme dans la silicon
valley du néolibéralisme et de
l'économie de la libre entreprise mais
ils sont plus démocrate que républicain
hillary clinton était très proche d'eric
schmidt et mark zuckerberg est très
proche de beaucoup de grandes figures du
parti démocrate
donc beaucoup de monde plus important du
parti conservateur pense qu'il ya une
injustice et cela s'applique également
sélection justement quel est le mot pas
vous parler des élections ces menaces
interviennent on le fait à cinq mois de
la présidentielle beaucoup de choses
vont se jouer sur les réseaux sociaux on
imagine que c'est un enjeu majeur
remporté donald trump évidemment tout à
fait beaucoup d'américains prennent
leurs décisions en fonction de ce qu'il
voit par exemple sur facebook ou twitter
ou sur internet en général
si les géants technologiques de la
silicon valley sont un monopole et qu'en
plus on beaucoup d' influence politique
et sont partiaux envers les démocrates
alors beaucoup de personnes disent qu'il
ya une injustice flagrante
ils peuvent effectivement influencer
l'opinion de plusieurs millions de
personnes et donc leur vote
donald trump at il la possibilité
d'aller à l'encontre de cela au niveau
constitutionnel cela reste à voir
car effectivement il s'agit
théoriquement d'entreprises privées
cependant même le département de la
justice se remet en question un
situation et twitter a accusé le
président des états unis de propager des
théories du complot et encourage les
gens à ne pas le croire et pour beaucoup
de personnes
c'est un comportement complètement
inapproprié merci clairement pas un jean
levi's politique pour rta américain
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir en direct
des états unis